i think i'm going to really regret
opening this can of worms
[Music]
video games are something i
rarely talk about
on this channel or on break room of
geeks go ahead subscribe over there if
you haven't
uh get the plug in early you know as
long as you can get it in smoothly it's
fine
don't know how smooth that was
should i have lubed it up more
i need to stop this train of thought in
any case it's a topic i don't talk about
much
and when i do
it's usually
more or less in a retro sense i've
talked about what i consider to be my
favorite video game or other video games
that i had really good experiences with
but i haven't talked about anything more
current than ps3 because
that's
that's what i have so
i'm not a gamer in the current active
sense but i've been a gamer
i've had video game consoles in my life
since i was in
first grade
so
they are a part of my life and i have
kept on top of what's been going on in
the industry for a while so despite the
fact that this is something you're not
used to hearing me talk about
it is something that i find myself
thinking about more than i might have
otherwise not just because of what's
been in the news in the last few years
but also
partially for the sake of my kiddo who
wanted one
i have
arguably a current gender maybe it's
considered last gen now but anyways i
have a switch
i haven't had a chance to play with it
very much
myself i haven't had time um but the
kid's having a great time with it
if you're a parent you understand
but
i now find myself also on the cusp of
buying a brand new computer which i
haven't had like i the laptop that's
right over there that i do my editing on
is also aside from my chromebook which i
only use for writing
the computer of the house and it can't
run current games but i'm getting a new
rig
i could in theory
i won't have the time realistically but
won't stop me necessarily from trying
but i could in theory
get involved in
more recent games stuff i haven't
touched
and the fact that that's a possibility
for me
does open up the question
with everything that's been going on in
the video game industry
in the last few years that does not
appear to be getting much better
what do we do
i know it might sound weird saying we
but
i think
i think more people care
about
what the abuses
of the industry are be they the abuses
of the customer base of the employees
the workspaces whatever it may be
i think a lot more people care than are
prepared to admit to
they may not be happy with the fact that
they care but think about it
if
people didn't care
about the fact that
there is now a massive
lawsuit
detailing horrific
working conditions and abuses towards
employees especially women and
especially women of color at activision
blizzard
if people legitimately
didn't care that that was going on
they wouldn't get upset
at other people talking about it
not to say that that's a healthy
response but when people attack
creators like james stephanie sterling
or anyone who brings up these issues on
twitter youtube a podcast whatever
the reason that
people lash out is
because they care
they don't want to have to think about
that because if they
think about it if someone reminds them
of it if they cannot ignore it
well then they have to deal with it and
they don't want to have to do that and
they will get angry at anyone who tries
to who they feel is trying to make them
do that but if people flat out didn't
care if they said people get abused in
the workplace
i don't care
if that was actually true they wouldn't
even be complaining about other people
talking about it
but they do
so
where do we go
because
the scale
and the ubiquity
of the abusive conditions in the video
game industry is
to some degree
almost across the board
developers and publishers of every size
the biggest to the smallest the triple
a's to the indies
there are problems
everywhere there are problems of culture
there are problems of predatory
monetization of the games themselves
that take advantage of vulnerable people
in their customer base there are
problems of so many stripes from just
forcing people to crunch not paying them
properly for their work and then firing
them before you have to pay out bonuses
people at the top forcing things to go
out before they are ready and then
cutting the jobs of the dev team when
the response is not what they wanted a
dev team that would have known fully
well that the game wasn't ready but the
people at the top and the publishers
said tough it goes out right now and
then they fire
people companies like activision in
addition to the litany of allegations
now against them
they have on multiple occasions
posted record revenue and then in the
same month fired hundreds of employees
this industry
is
not in a good shape
perhaps if i'm being honest
the truly ethical thing would be to
not play video games
but i'm not going to ask that of anybody
and i'm not prepared to do that just
because the industry is as screwed up
and as many levels as it currently is
does not mean that it cannot get better
so while i'm not necessarily going to
say well we can't just burn it to the
ground i'm like
maybe we could burn some of it to the
ground
so let's narrow the focus a little bit
three of the biggest
developers and publishers out there and
creators of some of the most popular
video games
are ubisoft
blizzard
and ea
and unfortunately
all three of them have massive issues
not all the same issue
but it varies quick rundown ea
one of the worst in terms of the
exploitation of its employees in terms
of crunch cutting jobs buying up
companies and then dissolving them
shortly after they
chew employees up and spit them out
in a way that is not that dissimilar to
most of the industry but obviously on a
much larger scale because they're a much
bigger company
and of course there's also some of the
worst predatory monetization but i don't
i don't want to dwell too much on that
element of it at least not here
ubisoft
had a culture of of enforced silence
about abusive heads of teams
directors of games developers people in
management
who were routinely
abusing and harassing in horrifying and
often sexual manners
and
that went on for years
and according to the most recent
indicators not from the people at the
top who of course want to say
everything's fine now but from the
people who are still working there
those people still unemployed at ubisoft
say things have not improved and they
have not changed and then there's
activision blizzard
which similar to ea
had the
bad treatment of employees as a resource
that we can just cut loose at any time
issue but now we have
massive details
on the
prevalence and just how deeply it ran
this culture
of misogyny
and abuse and how casual
it was for male employees and managers
to ridicule abuse and mock
anyone who wasn't just like them
which is to say straight cis white male
because that's the majority of anybody
higher than a team lead was now
definitely in the case of ubisoft and
activision which
while i think it's actually still
currently more popular to hate on ea i
think that has to do with the fact that
ea's
abuse of its players is more prevalent
and seeps into the games themselves more
meaning it's hard to play a game
released by ea and not see the predatory
ways in which
the monetization the microtransactions
the in-game economies work
they're one of the most shameless
you know everything from the loot boxes
of fifa to what happened with the
insanely negative result of the second
star wars battlefront game they have a
long list of things that you can't
you could avoid all the business news in
the world but you would play the game
and go this is screwed up
so it's easy to hate on ea i think for
some people slightly harder to hate on
activision or on
ubisoft
because
in those two cases especially activision
blizzard
they make some still very popular
titles
ubisoft's big thing still currently
assassin's creed but they also have far
cry they have the tom clancy games and
there are people who very much love
those and activision blizzard i mean
activision has call of duty and then the
blizzard end of it they're working on a
new diablo
they've got overwatch world of warcraft
hearthstone
all kinds of games that are
beloved games because they're good or at
least we're good at one point
and that makes it harder i am going to
now say two things
i am of the belief
that
the only reasonable thing
is to no longer
support these companies
but i'm also going to immediately say i
understand how hard that is this sounds
small
but
i play hearthstone it used to be
what i played
on my live streams on my twitch channel
i've moved on to other things now
because i don't
feel comfortable
doing anything that publicizes
blizzard
owned property anymore but
it's been hard for me to actually delete
the game especially off my phone
because it's become part of my routine
and i don't mean like a habit i mean
i have adhd
sometimes to calm my brain i need to be
doing something with my hands i only
need to half think about while doing
something else
while waiting for a newly dropped clip
to render i'll work my way
through the battlegrounds mode
that's become part of my routine it's
become part of how i manage my own
neurodivergence
and i'm having a hard time stopping now
i can point out i've actually never
spent a single penny on hearthstone at
any point and i definitely won't now
and while i feel better about having
taken it off my twitch
schedule
i wish it was easier for me to just get
rid of the game
and i know in the case of something like
world of warcraft there are people who
have sunk
a lot of time into that i don't just
mean like it's a commitment of time
therefore you have to keep you i mean
people have built
friendships people manage their mental
health partly through
the time they spend in world of warcraft
and i would never say
that they should get rid of it
if you are able to that might be a good
thing but i understand
i do
and i would not say that you
need to get rid of anything you've
already bought much like
when
i had to cut loose
harry potter related stuff in the wake
of jk rowling
being all jk rowling all over the place
i don't begrudge anyone keeping the
things they already had
i know that those things can and will
still have value and where you fall on
that and how you process that's
gonna be something that everyone
determines
on their own
but i don't think it's a good idea
to support
any of these three but most especially
ubisoft
and activision blizzard
at this point
and
i would say the first thing that would
have to happen
to consider
starting to
work with their stuff and purchase their
stuff support their work again
is the heads of the companies need to go
because in both cases they've offered up
sacrificial lambs
they have let go of
certain named individuals either because
those people were directly implicated in
these scandals or just to offer somebody
up
the head of blizzard is gone but
bobby coddick the head of activision the
parent company is still in place
and yves juamo
the owner and head of ubisoft has not
budged
and even though
lots of the quote-unquote offenders
were
supposedly released from the company
they all got to keep their bonuses
and
as i've said the indications right now
are the internal culture hasn't changed
even with these individuals gone
there used to be a time
when a scandal this big out of company
meant whoever was at the top
didn't matter whether or not they were
directly implicated but they went
that used to be standard
because
when something like this happens
one of two things has to be true
either
these people at the top
did not know what was going on
but given the scale and size of the
problem
and how long it was going on
and how many accounts there are from how
many people underneath them who tried to
make these things known and did within
the company if they
had no idea
then they weren't properly managing the
company and they suck at their jobs and
they should be gone
or the alternative is they did know and
did nothing about it in which case they
are callous bastards who
have no regard for the people who are
employed by them in which case they are
bad at their job and they should be gone
the fact that the heads the ceos of
these companies are still in place right
now to me says
they don't
want to change they want to change the
perception of them ea is actually a
really good example if you go back a few
years they complained about being listed
as the worst company in america two
years in a row bobby kotak head of
activision complains about being
perceived as the bad guy
they care about how they are viewed they
don't care about what they actually do
they only care what people think about
it and the instant we stop reacting to
it
is the instant they can go right back to
it
and that's what i mean by not supporting
them anymore any new purchase you make
of their products
tells them that
it's blowing over
and that there aren't consequences
and
to to make a bit of a comparison
the closest equivalent
scandal that i can think of that's
happened in another entertainment
industry
was with harvey weinstein
now
harvey weinstein as a producer and the
head of a studio
a couple of studios over the years being
as abusive as he was for as long as he
was
and it taking so long to happen is an
indictment of inherent problems within
the movie-making industry absolutely it
is it was and it still is
and not as many people were held to
account as should have been
however his
offenses
his crimes that he's now in jail for
weren't done on the job his position of
power that he held
was what enabled him to do this and he
was taking advantage of people within
the industry so the industry was
absolutely a factor in this but he
wasn't
going to active movie sets
and doing these things
this was off the clock
this was off hours and that doesn't make
it okay in any way but the point that
i'm making is
the actual sets are usually a
relatively safe space
due in no small part to the fact that
hollywood is a very union-heavy town and
virtually everybody working on a set
from the director to the actors to the
writers to the people hanging the lights
to the makeup artists
they are in a union
and they have some degree of protection
and they have people they can go to
who will go to bat for them they're not
forced to go to a company hr manager who
is not actually interested in protecting
the employees but instead protecting the
company that's what hr does that's their
job
so even when
someone like harvey weinstein was
exposed
arrested
tried convicted
rightfully
it's not a full condemnation
of
the movies made under him
or the
other people at the studios he ran it is
a condemnation of a lot of stuff in that
town again
a lot more people should have been
implicated than probably were
but it is one guy taking horrifying
advantage
as opposed to something baked into the
system that is going from the top
down
so
at the very least
what can and should happen at these
video game companies is that these
people get removed from their top
positions but it hasn't
and no these people being gone suddenly
won't mean everything's fine because
there's obviously people underneath them
that are a problem there's a mentality
there's a sickness at the heart
of a lot of these companies
but at the minimum the bare minimum
you get rid of whoever was in charge
while this was going on that hasn't
happened
and until it does
i certainly
would not be comfortable putting
any money
towards anything they've made
and
as a creator i'm not even
really comfortable
praising anything they made even if it's
old
something that i was working on
for a long time actually and i was
finally getting ready to
start formally
um
shooting it
like i'd i'd written i finished the
script after plugging away at it for
years
and i had collected about half the
footage that i needed of gameplay
i was working on that i was going to
shoot and record my audio
i was going to do a retrospective on the
diablo franchise because i love those
games they mean a lot to me
and even in the script that i'd written
i'd had a i from the very beginning from
when i first wrote that thing i had a
caveat at the beginning basically saying
activision blizzard is a scummy company
that does scummy things i know that and
i'm not advising supporting them but i
still want to talk about these games
i was preparing to do that
and i've thrown all the work away
because i can't in good conscience
praise these companies
now
it's slightly different for me because
i'm a public facing figure
and the decisions that
you make on your own
aren't going to get public scrutiny as a
general rule unless you announce them
publicly so you don't necessarily have
to have the same
level of attention paid to
the things that you are talking about or
you know what's displayed on your shelf
behind you you know i used to have harry
potter stuff up there it's not up there
anymore
so
i i have considerations that other
people don't and
i needed to talk about this whole thing
because i know since i don't talk about
video games in general me just saying i
won't talk about any game put out by
activision blizzard or ubisoft or ea at
this point too um
that statement would have had no meaning
because i'm not known for talking about
any of these things but as someone who
has grown up on video games
as someone who was
excited
to finally be able to play
the
the modern stuff that i've been denied
for
over a decade now because i don't have
any i didn't have anything that could
run it
i still have to make a choice
i still have to do something
that
will help me
feel like i'm not contributing to the
problem
and again
i know
that it's hard
i have not been able to fully stop
playing hearthstone yet
i did delete the app off my phone
it was gone for
about a week
and
i
tried you know i tried getting by on the
other games i had on my phone see if
they would fill the gap it was quite
working i tried getting other stuff i
tried getting magic uh the arena which
people had suggested it wasn't
scratching the itch in the same way
and i re-downloaded it
it's still on my phone
i played it earlier today
and even knowing that
i was playing it to quiet my own mind
and deal with my own adhd
in a way that i know works
still doesn't feel great
but even i
filthy casual that i am
understand that this stuff is hard to
let go of
to my friends who are
deeply invested in world of warcraft
or the assassin creed games
or
whatever the hell ea hasn't completely
run into the ground mass effect i guess
i know that it's hard that's why i'm not
saying you have to get rid of anything
but
let's stop
hyping their new stuff
let's stop
buying
the new things and
when i say we i don't just mean you the
obligation should not lie solely with
the consumer a lot of it should lie with
the tangential industries
video game review
sites and video game media
should
well honestly should stop covering any
of the games that these companies make
and should run every single story about
the abuses
these companies should get only bad
press
until there is evidence uh that they are
even trying to legitimately change
because right now there really isn't
there is hand waving there is denials
there is token
changes that aren't really changes
as long as those things go on
there should not be a kind word said
about any of these companies
or their products
and before anyone tries to tell me well
that would just punish the developers
and they'd lose their jobs uh were you
not listening earlier they get fired
regardless
continuing to support these companies
will not protect them
a union might but this is
the worst time for me to get
a
semi-current gen
gaming console and a new computer
that can run games it's legitimately the
worst time
i'm gonna be playing so many indie games
i'm probably finding out most of them
were
subject to crunch and other nonsense too
ah
but
as
bummed out as all this
is what are your thoughts on it
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it
there's the usual stuff
stuff this stuff
like share subscribe
i don't know what happened
i have a patreon
and without that patreon
i would not be able to get a new
computer
so
that support is very much needed it
keeps this diary operation up and
running but you also don't have to do
that i've tried to make the point
throughout all this
your decisions are yours to make
and i just want you to remember
that you are
beautiful you are valid
you are loved
you
are the council
i'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
bye
[Music]